below are the steps Stephan use to
correctly solve the equation 6x is equal
to 3 times X plus 4 for X step 1 is
missing
what could Steven have written for step
1 so let's see so this is the original
equation we they give us a blank for
step 1 and then we see that he
eventually gets to 3x equals 12 that he
divides both sides by 3 and he gets 2x
equals 4 so the best way I could think
about doing this is just think well what
would I do
well if I saw something like this my
instinct would be to distribute this 3
so that I could start so I can start
separating the the parts of this
expression that have a variable that
have the X and the parts that are
constant so let's let's try to
distribute this 3 and see what we get
and see if that's a reasonable step for
the direction that Steven went in so if
we do that we would get 6x is equal to
we haven't changed the left-hand side
and the right-hand side 3 times X is 3x
and then 3 times 4 is 12 so you get 6x
is equal to 3x plus 12 now if I were to
just if I don't even look at what
Stephens doing right over here if if I'm
trying to solve for X what would be the
next thing that I would do well I would
try to isolate all of the X's on one
side and if I want all the X's on the
left-hand side I would subtract 3x from
both sides and so if you subtract 3x
from both sides if you subtract 3x from
both sides you would then get Stevens
second step right over here so this
looks like so this looks like a
completely reasonable first step for
Steven the first step is he distributes
the 3 to get this expression then he
subtracts 3x from both sides to get 3x
is equal to 12 and then he divides both
sides by 3 to get X is equal to 4